it takes f5 takes rookie jack king f1  queen f5 yep rook h5 so this was still  excellent for black and now look at two  right magnus blundered yeah rook takes  f2 wow  i mean this is just an extra pawn two  pawns right yep oh no it's only one pawn  but it's a  it's a horrible position for magnus yes  but the position was horrible in any  case  [Laughter]  sorry about that  but the problem is that that of course  queen h1 is a threat and after king g1 i  think white gets f3 so white cannot take  with the queen because the d4 pawn is  under attack  so  okay so this was a big miss by ariane  and he went rookie too this is surprise  for me that he went here exchanged he  took on d4 rookie one queen a4  okay he is better of course he has a  huge advantage no question